today we'll have a couple of games to go
over we'll do that first and the rest of
the time I have I have some games that I
like to show from the US Championship
that I played if we have time we'll do
it today if not the rest of the week
I'll be here so you're welcome to come
and see those lectures we'll all be
explaining you've probably seen the
games but there might be a lot of
details that you didn't see yet you know
once I start explaining what was going
on actually during those games so I
recommend to come if you can let's take
a look at this game this is a okay play
by Bill here let's see efore e5 Knight
f3 Knight f6 so everybody here should
let me ask you do you know the name of
this opening that block is trying to
play what's the name of this opening
uh-huh Russian game a Russian game also
known as the petrov okay so two names
you know if you Russia probably they
would say Russian again but you know
it's the same thing petrol I played
before as well this opening so Knight
takes e5 d six and here Knight f7
interesting very interesting sacrifice
of the night this is a gambit and played
by Alexei she'd off he had this position
and he played this Knight f7 very
interesting you know of course the most
common respond here is Knight f3 and
Knight takes e4 and here white has
several options you can play d4 he can
play Knight c3 so he has some options he
can do but Knight f7 just basically
eliminates all that and now it's going
to be a concrete position King takes f7
d4
g6 Bishop g5 activating the bishop very
good h6 let me ask you a question Bishop
g5 it's okay it's possible but which
other move looks quite natural to play
here to maintain the control of the
centre here that we would like to do 93
what was the reason that you didn't go
93 was anything specific or aha
okay the the only problem is the e4 pawn
still remains vulnerable and then he can
try to play this h6 g5 on you which
either you have to give up the bishop on
f6 or either you have to go back to g3
so you don't have too much choice there
now either you retreat or what to do
question is you know so that's what I
think it's probably you don't want you
want to keep all the pieces because when
you sacrifice material it's very
important if you're aggressive attacking
player you sacrifice a piece for two
pounds you want to keep as many pieces
on the board because that way you have
more attacking resources if you start
exchanging then you're going to have
less pieces so let's let's threads so
it's very important to keep all all the
pieces that's why I think 93 is
preferable to make sure that we know our
Center is protected and he cannot force
us anyway to exchange the bishop okay so
you play Bishop g5 h6 Bishop c4 check
King g7 bishop [ __ ] and now we see
this idea Bishop e7 wow that's a bit
strange decision I think he he was
afraid of something and he didn't play
the proper move okay black to play what
is the best move in this position to try
to take advantage of this bishop
maneuver that white did what's the best
thing to do here g5 questioning the
bishop now Bishop is question now what
to do he has to go back on g3 otherwise
it's saying you can't just takes the
pawn central pawn is gone and now I'm
not sure if we have enough because now
white is only a single pawn which is
just not going to be enough compensation
okay
quite
in h5m in but then okay I was thinking
about this but that weakens the e5
square so there might be this tactic now
right I think just simply Queen f6
protecting that and black will develop
his pieces and two will probably be up a
piece not much white a session huh well
I always have 93 ideas so not in danger
to get trapped here
so like f3 I can take take and just just
continue developing it just just not
enough you know there's just not enough
in the position here yeah yeah
absolutely
okay so Knight X but it's been strange
that he played this H it's yeah he
played the right moves and then suddenly
the crucial moment he's not doing this
he's doing this more your opponent plays
Bishop g7 Castle hmm
yeah why not why not protect enough to
make sure that he can do too much
because that central pawn is important
without central pawn it's just probably
going to be lost because not enough
compensation but with the central pawn
is different story I mean in this
position the best move would have been
Bishop takes f6 and I believe in this
position you would have some decent
compensation night goes on c3 then you
go Castle then you go F 45 launched the
attack you've got two central pawns some
leading development and you know it's
got a weak King so you can actually do
something here okay but it's important
so no Bishop h4n Bishop h4 Bishop e7 I
think still the best option here is to
take on f6
yeah yeah
yeah take one f6 yeah but but I mean
institution castle there you go f4 f5 93
I mean two pounds is 2 pounds and
especially you've got those central
pawns that slightly idea behind the
sacrifice when you give up a night
because you give up your night for just
2 pounds but you actually get those
central pawns so that's the difference
where you have a 45 and you can attack
here
okay so Knight f6 you canceled and yeah
and now black is going to play this g5
Oh bg5 bishop g3 Knight xe4 now Queen e2
plate attacking the knight Knight takes
g3 Knight takes G 3 plate yeah this this
might not you know this might not be the
most accurate move here
Knight XG 3 I mean it's a possibility
but I think probably better move is just
to play Bishop f5 developing the bishop
and
yeah I mean you know that Bishop cannot
move anywhere right
so immediately taking allows F takes G
and then some potential invention here
on f7 because he still doesn't have
development which will give you some
opportunities to try to attack but here
he could just continue developing it is
just normal way and good chances okay
for black to win but my g3 was played F
takes G three excellent opening up this
and now Oh case here where the notation
goes wrong okay it says Bishop g7 by
probably played Bishop f6 you know he
blocked you yeah so C 3 d6 Bishop b3
okay
c6 92 96 and Bishop C - excellent idea
Bishop council to do with idea of Queen
d3 Queen g6
because the weak diagonal right when
there is a weak diagonal what's the
common idea to do create a battery
battery is battery is when you have a
bishop and a queen on a diagonal and
usually you want to have the Queen in
front of the bishop because if the
bishop goes in nothing really happens
but if the Queen comes in it could be a
checkmate okay so it's very good idea a
very nice maneuver like we should see -
Bishop Bishop b3 Bishop C - and now it
goes Queen e1 Queen d3 okay ch5 yeah I
think yeah your opponent didn't play
didn't play solidly and now there is a
chance there is a serious chance here
and rook rook F 2 was played so look at
you look at the sack I'm sure but it's
that a good follow up though is there a
good follow up that's the question
because it looks very tempting but if we
don't have anything to follow it up with
then probably not enough you know I'm
thinking it's just not enough
unfortunately
yeah so you try to gobble but that gives
him time no that gives him time to also
bring his look into the game so
Oh keV - yeah Bishop d7 rook one f1 rook
a f8 Knight f3 white is down a piece but
imagine this is the extra piece that
black has so I'm here you can hardly see
the you know the existence of that extra
piece because it's just stuck on the
side of the board and black is just
fighting you know to not to get
checkmated here that's why you have a
good compensation here even though you
only have a single pawn Knight f3 rook
e8 was played wow it looks like a
blunder that looks like a blunder now
Knight comes in excellent takes takes 97
and e6 was played interesting hope
opens up diagonal look at six looks cool
yet threatened group g6 here but here's
this maybe no it's expose first yeah
this initial you should win this one to
Queen f5 now you want to go to cave
seven check
let's yeah this should win this now
because rook f7 comes in but you walked
out these six and you thought you were
just winning if it takes with the bishop
I guess the point is check here
check King goes here
should be winning but how
Oh check out
yeah I mean it feels like should be
winning here you got lots of material
here got the rooks
the Queen the bishop and just all of
them are just attacking putting lots of
pressure okay right yeah that looks good
but he played 96 and excellent idea here
g4
you always have to look for this kind of
ideas deflecting the defender defender
is the queen because it's just it's on
the verge you know defending f7 and g6
all you got to do is find the right
deflection and it will be a victory
because now takes checkmate
so Queen cannot go back the only thing
is to move this but then you have a
check you have a check here so opponent
late night f4 and you actually didn't go
check here huh you played rukka for how
about giving him a little check here
what is he going to do and then next
we'll simply take the Queen off the
board that's good - yeah I think you
took with this but the problem is now he
can just to take of course this is a win
check cannot go here has to go here
okay you win the bishop yeah I mean you
use the wind again but it's not us as
clean I think at this one this one is
just a little cleaner a little check and
goes back and pick up the Quinn take the
Quinn and then you will checkmate and
with extra Quinn got it okay so don't
take any chances
even in the winning positions don't take
any chances
okay that's that's the important thing
very interesting game very interesting I
mean probably the strategy was risky and
against maybe a little bit stronger an
experienced opponent probably wouldn't
work but I think block just you know
once black one the pawn it didn't play
well if you have a game that you like to
submit we can take a look we have
another game and Joe would color you are
you are black okay great okay your block
so let's flip the board and you are
playing against a strong player right
1800 so against 18 100 okay
efore g6 the interesting opening choice
why why do six why not anything like
fringe
caro-kann a5 c5 or you like playing this
unorthodox line okay and this is more
like a line that you can play without if
you don't know the theory and you don't
want to get cut into some preparation
you can play this but this is you know
eventually you probably want to work
work on it and get something a little
bit more solid than g6 and what's the
problem with this move you in general
what do you think is the first problem
with this move aha it's not fighting for
the center you're giving the center and
opponent will take it and what's
happening in this kind of perk sort of
positions you voluntarily give up the
center and then you start attacking the
center so you know if you can play
something that you actually fight for
the center in in the
immediately you'll be better off because
now you still have to try to equalize if
you place correctly you know which is
not going to be easier Bishop g7 C 3 aha
not the sharpest way to play against the
system a very sort of conservative way
why this aiming for a solid solid
position without complications 9 F 397
Bishop d3 d5 okay let's find de I'm not
sure about this so I think this most
simply makes your task much easier here
you know you can also just take back
with a pawn here it's not like it's
necessary for you to swap the Knights
because if you take Y this you can jump
in with a knight on here so it's not
like completely necessary to do this you
could do this but I think perhaps you
want to have some more pieces on the
board yeah now it's semi-closed yes so
take 9595 Bishop e5
F for Bishop g7 92 Knight f6 h3 Bishop
d7 any reason why we're not cancelling
what about the safety safety of the king
so you afraid of him launching an attack
on you okay Bishop d7 it's okay it's
fine Bishop e2 or c2 here
bit strange yeah not castling it's
strange why it's what did he tell you
why you move the bishop back why did he
go back yeah why don't you just better
hear Queen c2 I don't need bit strange
strategy h5 wait a minute I see a very
natural move for you very natural and a
good move for you that this one you must
play it's just asking to be played here
come on activating a piece with the
temple activating developing to better
square Bishop h6 yeah but then you place
g3 maybe or something why did you go
Bishop d7 what was your idea just to
castle
why didn't you just go here an attack
you win a pun you know that I simply
attack this pond three times now how can
why defend this let's analyze this
position
not too many options I can see well
push-pull you can push we take twice he
has to use this Bishop to protect right
so either has to go Bishop f3 or he has
to go to d3 goes here and who is going
to find a tactical idea that wins the
pawn here take take the pawn excellent
if you play d5 the problem he goes a5
he closes it so you go Knight takes e4
for a moment he may be like wait a
minute is giving me a piece no but you
got an idea behind it if I wanna go
shooting too pathetic maybe on this one
to have even bigger Center then you take
with FV and then you can support that
with D 5 so difference here in this case
that you can actually even go like this
take it goes back here you can even
chase them down from here and look at
that big Center you have and extra pawn
I mean you could also just Castle
castling would have been fine also but I
think I think this is just you know
close to be winning for sure you know
because you know white played strange
you know am i keeping the king in the
middle not committing and you know when
opponent does that you have to take
advantage of it okay you can let the
opportunity slip it away here it's it's
asking to be played you got two pieces
pressuring only four you got to get that
third piece out there right I mean this
a tribe was in accuracy okay make them
make a note
h5 instant of a tribe bishop c6
immediately you touch this pawn now he
needs to react somehow he goes Bishop
here or Bishop here doesn't matter same
concept we take he takes f5 getting that
piece back here now you even enjoy the
pair of the bishops you go here try to
get you know
you protect okay winning winning
position here after Queenie seven I
think you probably would have won the
game because you have better development
up upon excellent position h5 I think
you will be too worried about this g4
idea you know but opponent cannot do
this kind of things like his king is in
the middle if pieces are not well
developed I mean this g4 it's never
gonna work yeah but you give them time
to castle actually wait maybe maybe play
Bishop III air oh no looks a little bit
wait wait I just realized maybe UK
Bishop III in some point because it
looked like d3 but now I'm just
wondering UT play III or Bishop eat
maybe play Bishop III here okay so it I
couldn't tell from your writing it was D
or E so it's e okay that makes a
difference actually that makes a big
difference because then he's not moving
the bishop twice okay well yeah I
couldn't tell from the notation okay
take-take-take
so this is yeah at this better version
for for white yeah well for you sure
Pierce still I mean you're absolutely
fine here
I mean you're not worse or anything we
should be to Queen d7 Queen c2h5 yeah so
we got the same position but he's got
the bishop on e3 so the question is can
we do the same is it possible
still this move needs to be played here
you activating it and you are attacking
it you could say one two three you got
three on it now
how is it going to going to react now oh
I see you very nice move for you here
even better than this
IIIi very nice move you missed here who
can find a beautiful move the blackheads
here 94 maybe 24 but this is just
beautiful attacking the DASCO Bishop he
cannot retreat you win the pawn on f4 so
he has to take look at this pressuring
here pressuring here
opening it up when you got the bishop's
you want to open it up here I think we
have a huge position you can castle put
the rook on you eight I mean this is I
wouldn't be afraid to say that this is
probably close to be winning for you you
know cuz here you go here go here go
here go here you come in you come in
into his territory
III nice shot you missed a nice
opportunity here you put that knight on
d5 end of excellent winning chances
knight on d5 putting pressure h5 long
Castle b5 now I don't like the strategy
you push from here you push from here
here
we should before that's a very cute idea
checker now you lose the Queen because
if you go to f1 you get 493 if you go to
D 1 you get 493 either way you go you
get forth game is over you win you
didn't see 95 lose loser when opponent
has a loose piece also known as LPD all
right loose piece drop-off so what do
you do yeah lose pieces drop off here
loose when you see opponent there's a
loose piece you need to look for those
ideas the tactics here that's a loose
piece we identify the loose piece and we
got some x-ray here right some
possibility so we have a little bit you
know we could see this here I mean it's
not that difficult I think to see yeah
you just got to look for it when
opponent has a loose piece you must look
for tactics tactics that will help you
to exploit that you know because if you
let them cancel solidify then he'll be
happy you know but 95 would have give
you excellent winning chances missed
opportunity h5 opponent Castle T at this
this is where things started to go wrong
and and I don't I really don't like I
really don't like this movie fire why
did you go b5 here
I understand but not with the king in
the middle
play a five and heaven play what no I
didn't want to play a four I didn't want
her to play for a for him in here yeah
why would you do this
wait wait like how many fishes are right
here okay well we need to do about this
we can't play with the King in the
middle guys we can never play with the
King in the middle that's just just rule
number one okay before we do anything
advanced we have to castle in a position
like this where it's about to explode
he's going to play e5 and open up the
position you can't afford to keep your
king in the middle it's going to open up
in a second and then it's going to be
big consequences here so what was your
strategy you wanted to cancel Queen side
right so why change that why can't we
just cancel then dropping this one well
he doesn't even need to do that you can
just win you a pond you don't have to be
six you get checkmated
we're about a six long castle
a sick sending castle then you put the
point on c6 and you start pushing
pressure on eforea opportunities and
opportunities
yeah b5 I don't like it now it's like
you neither can push castle here you
neither can castle here usually stuck
now Bishop f3 c6 shifted now it shifted
not to your advantage now I can just
play g4 human here he can even sacrifice
upon open up H file but he played he 595
Bishop takes d5 takes Knight f3 now
you're back in the game you know that
Bishop f5 Bishop f4 did you do that yes
you did you took you took I don't know I
don't know about take ish you know if I
have a choice I put my bishop here
cementec bishop Torino and now you
cannot do anything that Bishop is very
strong and then you know you wantem
actually to take this pawn because you
can open up the B file and you know you
have huge possibilities here just that
they should be strong you know that's
why you brought the bishop e you want to
just put it on that strong square and
then very very difficult for him to do
anything okay
yeah you play take
we should be five bishop gh6 g4
excellent now you want to take and take
he just blundered you winning now
you took this one h4 you closed it down
you don't want it to open okay
would it be better to bring this one
here why don't you go here actually I
mean that's a loose piece here right
that's a loose piece here so why don't
you just go here
oh you attack the Queen now he goes away
show me the tactic okay and let it let
it attack Bishop moves take this one
some wasn't really that worried about
the other work because he had keep
defending
yep
yeah okay you went through FDA Queen f6
what do you mean Queen f6 Queen f3 right
playbook AC 890 425 game over you one
right you lose
wait a minute you lose oh yeah yeah oh
yeah yah oof
the official takes place
I said my setback that hey I took some
time on this road I just take them yeah
I was getting happy with the rucksack on
c3 you relaxed yeah you're relaxed can
relax remember guys game is not over
until the opponent stops the clock and
reaches his hand energies I resign
okay say remember that you can never
relax it's a key lot of games are lost
and drawn in a completely winning
position just because of that reason one
player thinks it's just over and he
relaxes and opponent comes back you know
you're you have everything going for you
you got told totally winning position
and just take simple chess take okay
that's it you know you can put before
now you do your fun stuff I go so you
just you can just play one one simple
accuracy accuracy protecting it starting
to take in it
yeah that's what you had to do okay
tough game but a lot of things to learn
okay this was a very instructive game I
think because a lot of details okay so
one thing it's clear
do not play moves like h5 do not play
moves like g5 okay always have a clear
plan when you play chess think clear
okay and pay attention to the loose
pieces again identify the loose piece
which is the bishop on e3 start looking
for tactics when you see a loose piece
here and then things like this will come
into hand when you look for these
tactics 95 ideas you will see this yeah
you